hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones episode 6 video -
it totally cringe-worthy for a number of
characters in really horrifying amazing
ways new round of the giveaway also
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video so here we go careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet starting with top 7 moments number 7
Arya learns to play the game of faces
the last time we saw her she was just
learning to clean the bodies now she's
starting to wonder what happens after
the weight teases her with this really
interesting story about being the
daughter of a lord who killed her
stepmother and then fled to join the
faceless men is actually right out of
the books she really is the daughter of
an ancient noble house they never say
which one but you guys are left to
wonder in the context of the book she
said to be about 36 years old which is
pretty close to how old Cersei is
supposed to be the reason she appears so
young is supposedly because she spent so
much time working with poison it's
affected her the game of faces itself is
all about lying learning to lie
convincingly
that's why jaqen was whipping her
because he didn't believe when ru was
telling her story even though she was
telling the truth that she was narrating
everything that happened to her since
season 1 it just it didn't sound real I
guess to him I believed her but Jack ins
a tough nut to crack it's not until she
helps the little girl lying convincingly
saying you know that the water heals her
that the show tells us she's learned the
game of faces that moment felt a little
contrived I mean that was all about Jack
and realizing that she had learned to
play the game of faces pawn to number 6
tyrion tells Jorah his father is dead
this is actually a pretty heartbreaking
moment I loved it it actually opened up
on him looking at the greyscale that
came right after jack and said the game
is never done I think the way they
edited that is just meant to imply that
the Jorah feels like he can only go
forward he knows he's gonna die so he
just has to keep going Jorah knew that
his father was at the wall though when
he was younger
Dory's father abdicated his throne so
that Jorah could ascend obviously since
then things kind of went to for
Jorah he got caught slaving that's when
he entered the services of the crown as
a spy on Daenerys I'd be willing to bet
that his father found out about that but
just that look of horror on jours face
when he finds out that his father was
murdered by his own men it just lets you
know that he still cares about him a lot
the show wants us to sympathize with Sir
Jorah even though I think the books
paint him in a less than pathetic way
the man's dying he just wants to serve
his Khaleesi I love the way he and
Tyrion argue back and forth what's gonna
happen once she becomes queen how do you
know she's going to be a good queen
Targaryens are famously insane all very
good questions on to number five Jack
and takes Aria into the Hall of faces as
she's walking down you notice there's
like many other corridors branching off
so there's many other levels to the
house of black and white that we haven't
seen yet the Hall of faces is just like
the most spectacular looking one
seriously it's like 20 30 foot high
ceilings which is faces piled to the
ceiling
look at how perfect those faces look -
they're just perfectly preserved they
went this far what I'm hoping is is that
we actually get to see a faceless person
apply a face like actually get to see it
happen they make it look like magic when
Jack and does it but it's more of a
practical thing you're literally wearing
someone else's face I know Jackie made
it sound like you know you lose your
tongue eyes like everything about you
technically it's really just the face
it's not just as simple as putting a
Halloween mask on but they'll probably
spell that out in future episodes
it is both grotesque and amazing you
guys lose your minds it'll be great when
he says she's not ready to become a
faceless person but she is ready to
become someone new this is just like her
getting ready to start her first mission
what do the faceless people do they kill
people for money so presumably we're
gonna get to watch Aria try and go kill
someone on to number four Tyrion and
Jorah get captured by slavers we finally
found out what mr. Eko is doing on the
show he's playing one of the slavers
that take tearing majora cut off his
and sell it dwarves are
magical people pay good money for that
stuff such a great callback to episode 3
when Tyrians like you should rub my
I hear it's good luck that is what you
get for being a smartass on Game of
Thrones
somebody count the number of times they
said in that scene he just barely
manages to save himself and then tries
to tell them that Jorah is like one of
the best fighters ever so that they
won't sell them into common slavery
they'll send me to the fighting pits of
Meereen where they're trying to go just
to explain the difference like if he
hadn't of gotten them to believe Jorah
is really great fighter they would have
been sold as common slaves and who knows
where they would have ended up by going
to the fighting pits they're that much
closer to Daenerys he'll be within
looking distance of Daenerys sneak and
say hey you know it's me sir Jorah and
remember Daenerys said no slaves allowed
in the fighting pits so technically
Jorah won't be a slave
but now we found out how he ends up in
this scene we saw from the the season 5
trailer and he actually is a really good
fighter I mean he's no sir Barristan
Selmy but he's pretty close that comment
they made about Sir Jorah being you know
almost 60 being a little over the hill
was a nice mirror for Aereo talking to
Jamie saying when you were whole this
would have been a good fight like yeah
both of these guys amazing fighters but
not quite in their prime anymore on to
number 3 Jaime and Bronn versus the sand
snakes this is so much fun and it's a
bit of a big departure from the book so
just to explain that first in the books
Arianne Martell convinces Aerys Oakheart
that they will put Myrcella on the
throne and supplant Tommen and Cersei
Marcelo will be the new queen of the
kingdom the sand snakes are just part of
that they get caught on the way to
King's Landing marcela gets her ear cut
off by dark star who isn't a character
on the show
Aerys oak art gets killed by Ariel with
his giant axe and the sand snakes get
put under lock and key so it's like a
failed version of what the sand snakes
are trying to do now
Ilario sand also got captured at the end
of this in the episode so it seems like
like that's the end of it so the big
changes are you know the glorious and
changed for Aryan Martel era so karte
changed for bran and Jaime and no one
died or got their ear chopped off we
still have four more episodes so there's
still plenty going on in this door and
storyline but it was just one of the
best fight scenes we've had in a while
bran amazing fighter you're pretty good
too for such a little girl and when you
punch Tristan out such a fancy little
boy does not look like a good fighter I
also love how that moment was preceded
by Aereo saying yes I definitely
remember how to use my axe when you were
whole it would have been a good fight
don't worry if this seemed like an axe
tease I do think we'll get to see him
use that sometime this season it's just
like a loaded gun sitting on the table
it's got to go off at some point on to
number two the high Sparrow puts Loras
and Margaery on trial Cersei has a plot
to get rid of the Tyrells Queen of
thorns isn't having any of it I love the
look that she gave Cersei at the end
when they were taken away there's no way
she's gonna sit on her but she was the
mastermind behind getting rid of Joffrey
or at least with little fingers help
Littlefinger also trying to play Cersei
against the north so I think
Littlefinger in the Queen of thorns will
form something of an alliance to get rid
of Cersei too but mostly it's the Queen
of thorns that has the motivation to do
it little little fingers playing the
long
Khan the Queen of thorns is trying to
get her family out of jail maybe it was
just me but it looked like Oliver really
enjoyed testifying against Loras like
maybe something was promised to him
maybe Cersei offered him gold whenever
they carried him away he seemed pretty
terrified and even if he made a bargain
with the faith he was still accused of
being gay with Loras so the church would
try him just like they would try Loras
they they give him the same punishment
so Flores was sentenced to death so it
Oliver so I don't see why he's so
excited but now we get to see this
awesome twisted version of the trial
that Tyrion got last season whenever we
do get to the trial just look for
similarities between the Tyrion trial
scenes and you know whoever gets put on
trial in this season remember what the
high Sparrow said two kings and queens
are not above justice so it doesn't
matter who you are once you land on
their radar goes down and finally
under my number one WTF moment
Sansa gets married to Ramsay say yes to
the Winterfell dress Sansa's dress
actually was fairly beautiful even
though this whole scene was just
completely horrifying both beautiful and
terrible and notice how it started to
snow just as the ceremony started winter
has come how ominous inappropriate I
just love how the only smile in the
house right in this moment is Ramsay
everyone else either doesn't care hates
it or is terrified in the bedding scene
just took things to a whole new level
no no reek you stay here you watch
Ramsay had this creepy calm but that you
know then he started to slip into
classic Ramsay crazy you're not lying
are you that'd be a bad way to start the
marriage I think they did a good job you
know and that last scene painting in on
reeks face as he was watching what was
happening to Sansa is so much more
horrifying because you just you left to
imagine like your mind fills in the gaps
of what's happening with Sansa it seems
pretty clear that they're setting up
reek for some sort of redemptive moment
like he's gonna say enough is enough I
kind of expected him to do it in this
scene so here's my big question for you
guys how long do you think it's going to
be before reek
tries to save Sansa do you think he's
going to try and save Sansa I just felt
like that was what that whole last scene
was about like reek just being
completely horrified and if you think
about it he remembers his name he
remembered all the words of that wedding
ceremony so he very clearly has some of
his mind left like he hasn't completely
turned to mush the books are a little
more hazy on his level of sanity like
sometimes
have trouble remembering things like
he's so fully become this reek character
the show just seems I could tune that
down just a little bit like he's a
little closer to Theon than he is tarik
so I'm just waiting for reek bomb to
explode all over Ramsey's face there was
so much talk of dwarf I was
actually kind of hoping that reek would
try to cut Ramses off like it would be a
nice twist on what Ramsay did tarik I
feel like that would be a nice way to
close Rameses Arc but he's such an
interesting character that the show
might not kill him off for a while
that's really the problem with
characters like Ramsay you know bad or
good the more interesting you are better
chance you have for staying on the show
let's circle back around to Littlefinger
real quick to because he actually says
something really important for this
northern storyline make me warden of the
north
if I can get rid of the Bolton's
technically Sansa would be warden s of
the North now but don't think that
Littlefinger is trying to sell Sansa out
I still think that he cares for her in a
really weird way what he was trying to
do is just play King's Landing against
the Bolton's because supposedly they're
supposed to be helping the Bolton's but
if he convinces Cersei that they're
double-crossing them then he can break
that alliance he's just trying to cut
the Bolton's off from all their support
wait for Stannis to march in see how it
goes down and then take down the winner
don't forget to Breanna is staying in
winter town right near Winterfell so
hopefully we'll get to see how she's
going to try and help Sansa overall just
a terrifyingly amazing episode don't
forget though Q&A is going to post
tomorrow announce the winner of my Q&A
remember all you have to do to enter
those is just be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
to learn all about the Targaryen
restoration that they're doing on the
show and some changes from the books and
you can click here for last week's
episode thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow
Oh